all right guys we're going to savor
these warm temperatures today and
beautiful skies out there yeah we've got
contrails crisscrossing out there and
light light winds but we will make up
for that get a few breezes going for the
weekend lots of 50s around the valley
this morning's been pretty mild we hit
78 yesterday we're shooting for 80s
different kind of fireworks
going on in california this weekend with
big storms blasting there now we will
get the warmest day of the week today at
83 a bit breezy and cooler for the
weekend more clouds on sunday ahead of
that final system out of california that
will finally sink southward into
southern california then we'll get the
leftovers of it on monday and there is a
pretty good chance of us getting some
rain storm number one in this series of
three they've already had a preview of
showers in the last couple of days but
this one is delivering some pretty heavy
rain in northern california up through
washington storm number two is up here
in the gulf of alaska they've got gale
force wind warnings up there in the gulf
of alaska but storm number three the one
that will hit later in the weekend is
still behind that one and that's the one
that's being labeled a bomb cyclone
extremely deep low pressure like a
category 3 hurricane and that's the one
that's going to blast into the west
flood watches all through the burn areas
rain moving through along i-5 and
eventually the rain will start to move
southward
maybe a half a foot to a foot of rain
that's going to produce flooding in the
wildfire burn areas and then maybe five
to seven feet of snow in the sierras
mammoth mountain is going to open two
weeks ahead of schedule a week from
today
they plan on skiing on a couple of the
runs at mammoth mountain they anticipate
so much great snow we'll stay dry we'll
see periods of high clouds waves of high
clouds kind of coming through but again
so warm at 83 degrees a little cooler
with some south breezes tonight and
tomorrow upper 70s for the weekend still
comfortable but more clouds ahead of
that last system on sunday that will
bring us a pretty good chance of rain
between noon and say six or nine o'clock
into the evening hours monday and then
we'll be cooler behind it good sunshine
tuesday through friday we'll be right
back up to 80 next week heading into
halloween weekend oh just a week away
yes it is